У цьому відео студенти богослов’я з Тюбінгена
оспівують репом Мартіна Лютера, жартівливо
називаючи його "босом з Віттенберга".
Рівно 500 років тому, 31 жовтня
1517 року
Лютер прибив до дверей собору у Віттенберзі свої 95 тез.
У них він, зокрема, критикує
торгівлю індульгенціями - відпущення гріхів за гроші
та перетворення страху людей перед пеклом у бізнес.
Мартін Лютер також переклав Біблію німецькою мовою.
Таким чином Святе Писання стало  доступним
і для звичайних вірян.
Багато хто навчився читати саме завдяки Біблії.
В подальшому протестанти відкололись від католиків,
створивши нову церкву.
Вони більше не визнавали владу Папи в Римі.
Це призвело до  битв за владу та воєн у Європі
упродовж багатьох століть.
Протестантський рух перетворився на щось більше за релігію,
і  його наслідки відчуваються донині.
Те, що розпочалося як дискусія,
суперечка через свободу християн,
свободу віросповідання християн,
перейшло у боротьбу за звільненння від примусу
та пригнічення або, як я кажу, у свободу відповідальності".
Кожен четвертий німець сьогодні є членом лютеранської церкви.
Більшість протестантів мешкають,
однак, у інших частинах світу
В Африці – 160 мільйонів.
В Азії – більше 62 мільйонів.
Загалом у Європі – майже 118 мільйонів осіб.
У Північній Америці - 172 мільйони.
У Латинській Америці – 61 мільйон протестантів.
У День реформації протестанти в усьому світі
святкують спадщину Мартіна Лютера.